It's going on, everybody. Yas,
this is the gayest podcast in the universe because it's pride month.
So let's get the gout.
[Inaudible].
Happy, pride everybody. I'm Chrissy in the closet. Um,
but I'm out of the closet today. Um, I just got, I went, um,
on a website and I just bought a shirt. I'm going to post a picture of it.
It's it's a shirt that says finished him and it's two guys blown each other.
It's just what it is. Listen, today is going to be a good episode.
It's gay pride. It's it's June. Um, you really feel it here in the West village.
You feel it right in your, in the West village. Um,
and so we're going to talk about Michael Angelo who make no mistake was a gay
kid that loved to paint. And he listen,
Michael Michelangelo was a kid beautiful painter,
but make no mistake that kid behind closed doors was doing a little bit of
spinning the wheel. He spun the wheel a few times.
In-between his muddy, cheat commission sculptures that can pick a few eggplants.
Because the truth of the situation is, and I know it's an unpopular opinion,
but if you're a man and there's nothing wrong with this,
but if you're a man and you're a hairdresser or you're an artist,
or you're a nurse, you're just a gay guy. You just,
you just got a little bit of gay in you and that's okay.
I was a pediatric physical therapist and they said the women,
it's mostly a female, uh, job oriented job. And the women, when they first, uh,
when I first got to they're like, you have to be gay. And I was like,
I'm not gay, but now 10 years later, guess what they were, right?
Yeah. Cause they predicted the future. You just couldn't see it at the time.
Cause you had pushed it down. Yeah. I pushed it down. But now make no mistake,
pulling it up because your buys are.
I'm by buzzer and my father's diabetes is getting uncontrollable.
So he's getting close and the Gates common out.
It's creeped out every time every, every, every time my dad's sugar goes up,
I get a little bit closer to sucking a.
What it is just going to come up.
But I've noticed that like the tries used to be strong.
Cause you were pushing it down. Yeah. But now that you're pulling it out,
you're letting the gay up.
Your buys are starting to show a little bit cosmic numbers by yeah.
Pun intended. Yeah.
Hi intended one day. Make no mistake. I'm going to pull one right into my mouth.
Yeah.
Because out we need an animator please. Whoever you are out there,
we know we got a few photos. I need you to make the cartoon where Chris is.
Uvula is getting hit by a Dick and it looks like a speed bag. It's what it is.
Especially since you throw hands, we need.
It. It's raining out. It's a beautiful day in [inaudible].
Should we just do this whole podcast and stereotypical gay voice in honor of the
LGBTQ community?
Well, the thing is yes. I want to say yes,
but it's 2019 and there are a lot of straight men,
straight white men that have wives and children that talk like this very proudly
father's day on Sunday.
Happy father's day to all the fathers out there and shout out Smith, tell water,
shout outs to tell water department happy father's day to anybody.
Who's got a Dick or it's just everyone, you know, whether you have it,
we're born with it. He got a postop happy father's day. Yeah. Um,
so one of the,
one of the dads on the thread that we have that we communicate
with was like, Oh, you know, donuts. Um, I know it's donuts with dad,
but don't you think it's a little, we shouldn't be giving our kids.
We shouldn't be promoting donuts and Cody make it something else.
Could we make it like a fruit? And I said a second, this is the moment I know.
And I'm certain of that. Crystal clear, Chris, he turns into steel pipe.
Chrissy here at here comes yet. And I said, look, guy,
I said thing is if you're a freak of a kid, right?
Cause you're a freak. Make no mistake. You're a freak.
If you're riding that on a public forum to the school,
you're a freakazoid. Okay. You're in Bay Ridge, Brooklyn. Okay.
He's making you not feel comfy one feet. Yeah. He's making me not feel comfy.
Wumpy okay. This is in Portland, Oregon.
We're going to make that a t-shirt Mike, write it down comfy.
He's got to be sharp, comfy feet and spin the wheel.
The thing is your kid. I know that sugar is bad. I know it's the enemy.
I listen. I know that sugar and white men are the enemy.
I know those are the biggest problems that we have in the United States are
sugar and straight white men. I,
I I'm aware if you don't think Michelangelo painted his a little bit, but yeah.
I mean, here's the thing. I mean, it was different being gay back then though.
Yeah. He had one, uh,
it's disputed whether it was a lover or not. Nobody knows. But uh,
his name was uh, Tomasa [inaudible].
1833.
He wrote to Michelangelo saying I flee from evil deeds and wished to flee
them for, I cannot make love with anyone, but you okay?
That's positive. Yeah. Kid want to bang out a little bit. He's a gay kid.
He's a gay kid. He said he wants to make love with anyone. But this kid Thomas.
Exactly. So this is one of the sun. It's that? His nephew,
when he published his son, he changed. He made her all these pumps,
his subject female. But it's that line right there. Cause it's not a fact.
Nobody knows for sure if he was gay, but look right. He liked to sculpt.
He liked to sculp man. And they looked hot. They looked hot. He had no wife.
He had no kids. And he always hung out with this kid for decades.
This kid was actually at his funeral. He was by his side the whole time.
And um, this was the kid he loved. So he was also,
and he also went with his full first name, which according to my father,
Tony Dak, Fred Flintstone. If you go with your full first name, Michael Angelo,
Steven, you know Jonathan, it means you're a gay kid.
If he would've went in his mic, it's a different thing. But it's a pretty,
a foolproof theory. Three things like, yeah. If like any guy in that,
like if you introduce yourself as Steven, he'd be like, you would,
this guy sucks. Yeah. I'm trying to think of Mateo.
It's all what you shorten it you'd be like Matt,
if it's four letters or Underlink, if it's John or Joe or something like that,
then it's no problem. But if you're over a few letters, like you Yonis,
he's like cultural. He doesn't know what to make of it, but you know? Yeah.
Like if, if, if, if Mike Marsh was Michael mush, he'd be like, yeah,
what's easy gay guy. He said what? The guy, most young probably is gay kid.
His name's Michael. Yeah. So your father,
probably everyone has the one Greek friend that called the Greek. Right?
Cause I had a friend Demetrius the Greek, the Greek. Yeah. Yeah.
He would just call them D the Greek DataGrid I posted a picture of myself in
front of a, uh, a thing, a thing I saw on Friday,
down in the West village that said, mom, mom, I'm gay. And I told him,
I posted a picture of me in front of it. Yeah.
And I got all these messages from gay people being like,
thank you for being an ally. I think if you're being an ally,
it's like the fact that people want to hurt gay people.
It's just beyond my comprehension. Why you would want there's what,
what do gay people do it, they control the population. fantastic.
Yeah. It's a Gretta. Great. Yeah. Thank you for your service.
Absolutely. Thank you. Because you know, some of these kids, like I'd rather,
I'd rather have gay guys running around than some of these,
some of these children that, you know,
are just a little annoying and not at the beach.
Yeah. I just, you know what I mean? Yeah, yeah, yeah. I beach goers. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. You don't send these kids washing off.
Here's the thing.
Wait, shuts yet. Here's the thing. We also can't act like, listen,
if you go to a neighborhood and you see a lesbian couple walking around and it's
a dangerous neighborhood by a house in the neighborhood that that neighbor is
about to get cute. Lesbians are like the Marines of gentrification.
They're in the first tough lesbians, like park slope.
We started seeing lesbians walk around and uh,
that's when you supposed to buy a house,
cause that neighborhood's gonna flip gay people make, look nice. Right?
Our gay peers. I mean Matteo lane, the creativity, the vision that,
that the talent of that kid has off the charts, Tim Dylan,
a totally different kind of gay. He's like a straight gay guy,
just straight gay guy, but still his mind,
the way it works like to lose gay people is to lose like the most creative
people we have.
So Tim Dillon is his kind of guy who wants to the out of Mateo a hundred
percent. Right. But he never can. He never.
Now if Tim Dillon. Yeah. If, if Rogen,
if one day decides to step away from Tim Dylan's career,
Tim Dillon is going to be like, this could make it Michelangelo [inaudible]
He was born in caprese. And then Kim was an artist,
mother died or the mother died or the mother, he had the father situation,
the mother, the mother died early shoot,
which I think she drank herself to death. Yeah. Um, and uh,
and then he would go on to create the, the biggest thing is the Sistine chapel.
He was raised by a well, let's be, let's be honest.
A lot of my friends think it's a 16th chapel chapel.
So I think there's 15 other ones. So that's, there's no,
there's no mistake. The 16 chapel pie, Patty fly balls,
Debo warm my boys like that. They think that it's 1500 ones and he did the 16.
Eight questions. You're going to, then you go into six to eight while we'll.
Meet me in deep will be going back to 12th and 13th. We're going to go off to,
we're going to go into water. We want to see them in order.
So we're going to start at one. These guys starting at 16, the idiot.
He thought painting was gay Michelangelo guy. He really thought it was.
And uh, he, he hated when people referred to him as a painter.
That's why he reluctantly painted the Sistine chapel. It was a,
he,
I think he did sculptures for like 12 Pope's or whatever the hell it was a lot
of Pope's. But he, one of the Pope's asked him to, to carve his,
um, mausoleum, his tube. Yeah.
Well his most famous work is St. Peter's Basilica.
I signed that. I think he was an architect behind that, which is crazy. Yeah.
I don't think he actually.
Built it. He was a Renaissance man though.
Didn't he also have an original version of a plane in like the 16 hundreds that
was Leonardo da Vinci.
Close enough. Yeah. They lived at the same time when she was a little older,
they actually didn't like each other. They were rivals.
They were really competitive with each other. Yeah. Yeah. But, um, um,
he did do with, uh, the piano, which is gorgeous. I've seen it in person.
I've been to Florence. Um, obviously the David and everyone says, well,
the David's got really big hands.
And the reason was because the David was initially supposed to be like
high up over the city. And they wanted the, the, they wanted, uh,
the [inaudible] family and all the politicians at that time,
the palace people wanted a bunch of big biblical characters all around the city,
but they realized how hard it was to lift David up.
So they just canceled all the rest of them in and just do the David.
And because it was so beautiful and the detail was so great,
they decided to have it lower so people could see all the details of right now.
So it's in Florence, they're just in Florence, just in Florence, in the museum.
So it's behind, you know, you can't even see it. It's so the, the,
the mob of people that go to see it, but it's really big. And there it is.
And he's got a tiny piece, but you know what?
Mediterranean kids were grown big head till he does have a big head, but they,
they made him Michelangelo made those proportions,
the big head and the big hands,
because this sculpture was initially meant to be a pie.
You're supposed to be looking.
Up at it. Yeah. But.
If, but it's piece, those stayed small.
Peace States won and he gave him pubes. So the kid had fumes. Yeah.
They couldn't, they couldn't manscape back then everybody had phones. Yeah.
And he had big camp. Me who knows me, big hands, you know,
but maybe that could be maybe one of them a bit cans. Maybe that's his fantasy.
Yeah. And maybe he was a grower, you know,
maybe one of the first put the piece in the mouth.
It felt like you were doing a little bit of picking a blanket,
but then it grew up.
She would question me as you're looking at this statue. Darn, absolutely.
The book scroll down. Yeah, we got it.
There's only one thing with Yani the feet, but look at the feet.
What do you think it looks to be? Can we zoom in on the feet?
Because that's the only thing that that's Yani is only thing is you got to have,
you can't have jacked up feet. He's not going to go down there.
I'm not going to crack you open and clean you out.
What do you think of the feet? Do they do a nice job on the feet? Let's see.
Kids got nice feet. He's got long toes doll.
So if I could press a button and make David come to light,
if you put that foot right in your mouth.
My mouth, cause would you bag him out? Would you crack open and clean up?
David I'd spin the wheel with David. He was obviously a gifted,
talented guy to be able to do this stuff. Like my friend,
Jesse [inaudible] can do sculpt and paint. You're just born.
I could not paint you a Smurf. I can't draw you a Smurf. Everything.
I draw looks like a stick figure. This,
he carved that out of marble with a chisel.
He took a block of marble and made that look like that.
Like how do you even begin to comprehend how to do that is
unbelievable. But anyway, the [inaudible] family was a,
they were bankers and they were like the most powerful family.
This was during the Renaissance in Florence,
they controlled Florence and they commissioned him early on the DC family.
Like he started working for the DDGs, like 17. Then he started working.
I became famous, uh, the piano. It was like his first big, um,
sculpture. And it made him absolutely famous. The piano. There it is. That is,
um, and I think the piano, I think it, it means pity right in English. Does it,
you know? And it's the Virgin, Mary who you're,
you shouldn't be making your cross right now. Yeah.
It's a Virgin Mary and there's a dead Jesus. It's brutal, but it's an absolute,
beautiful, beautiful sculpture. And from there he got famous.
Then he was asked to, uh, create the tomb for the, for the, for the Pope. Um,
he went to Rome, um, and, and painted the Sistine chapel reluctantly,
because he didn't want to be a painter. And plus,
nobody wanted to do that job because you have to lay on your back and do it.
Right. It's wild.
The way he painted that is wild on his back on this huge scaffolding.
And it's not like it's not a key at helpers.
He painted every detail of painted that himself. Yeah. You can't,
if you're a painter, you can't own a paint company. You have to do it.
You're the one that has the art to do it.
Crazy. Dude, the piano, he, he, he did the piano, that sculpture, which is,
I think a six feet by six feet block of marble.
He did that in a year, which is crazy.
And I think he did that in his early twenties.
Have you ever seen this stuff when you've been here?
I've seen it. I've seen the piano. I haven't seen the David,
but I have seen the piano in Florence. It's all in Florence and go to his Moses.
Right.
Okay. So some of his work is in Florence. Some is in Rome.
Have you seen the vintage area? You've been there.
Been there a couple of times. He's like one of my favorite artists. He's yeah.
Yeah. Cause you're not going to ever date a girl.
Who's been seeing the PR PR who's who's seen any of Michelangelo's
work in person. That's just not your.
Demo on what it is. You haven't been down the Jersey shore.
If you go to any museum and you see like how the Greeks did it, you know,
in their statutes and how beautiful they are. And then,
and then you walk to the Italian room.
You just like you forget about the degree. Key Greeks even existed.
That doesn't happen. No, it does.
Because th th th th the detail that the Italians have is un-fucking-believable.
And not only can they do it on a big scale, but they could do it.
Somebody statutes are microscopic, and these kids are cutting them up. You know?
Not only can they do a good sculpture.
They can also throw it out. Some good concrete in your backyard.
You know it right down. We need a pool built and you need it. You need some,
you need some marble or you need some masonry done. Yeah. Yeah.
Call Sally Goossens. Cause I guarantee you,
there's not a place in the world where the water doesn't move as,
it doesn't flow as smooth as it does in Smithtown. Smithtown.
Smithfield got good water. Good boy. Shouts. Shentel water department.
Does anyone need another water? I'd like to have another water,
but I also gotta pee, but.
Okay.
Okay. Wild about Italian kids, especially back then,
they do have long wild names because Michael Angelo's full name is Michael
Angelo de Ludovico [inaudible].
Wow.
Wow. But Greeks have long wild names still. Yeah, but we don't, you know,
the difference between Greeks is our, our names are long.
These guys have a lot of last names. I understand what you mean. Like,
what's your guy's name again? Who made the suit?
The Giovanni blush Yani. Jean brownie. Russia.
This guy's Michelangelo says Michelangelo de
[inaudible] [inaudible] yeah. That's his full name?
It's a full kid was born at 1475. I was born in 1975 and two cute kids. Wow.
300 years apart. Yeah. We're cute. Kids cuss. You look cute in 300,
500 years. Yeah. Look. Um, so Michael Angelo,
in closing in Nicole, he was a kid who loved to paint and spin the wheel.
He liked to spin the wheel. He was a gay kid. He was a gay kid today.
He'd be the most featured guests on Ellen. Yeah. I mean, look,
you got to just allow gay people to be gay people. They're just,
everyone's doing their own thing. And it's just like, mind your own mind.
Don't business. Let these people have fun.
Let these people live their life and do the right thing. You know, let them,
whatever they be happy. They're great parents. They're great artists.
And even if they're not into any of that, they're just great people.
Let them do what they want to do behind closed doors.
They're not getting into heaven. So either way, either way. Yeah.
Where's your machine, please. Zach, are you listening to our podcast?
He said believes it. Yeah. Kidding. Christ. Seriously. Shout out all my,
all my gay friends, you know,
only ones I can think of off the top of my head and tail lane, Tim Dylan,
Mike mush. And, uh,
so the thing about Michelangelo is his lover was so much younger than him.
This guy, he was this nobleman, uh, and that's all he had.
There's there's there's no, everything else is sort of a mystery.
There's no kind of recorded history on who exactly he was banging out,
but he definitely based on his writings,
which is all we know his letters to this kid.
He was obsessed with this young kid. Must've been a piece.
The kid must have been a piece on a nice little piece. And, uh, and yeah, man.
So support the gays. Happy pride. That was Michelangelo. Thank you guys.
And don't forget to subscribe. Also turn on alerts or to calm Cal frown.
Absolutely. And go to patrion.com/bay, rich voices, join the matriarch,
who things get really wild.